[MUSIC PLAYING]
COLT MCANLIS: For modern
mobile applications,
one of the easiest
performance traps to fall into
is drawing elements
too many times.
But the tools that are available
to help you detect and fix
this problem for
standard views frequently
don't help when you're using
highly customized views.
My name is Colt McAnlis.
And the trick to
fast performance
involves updating your code
to use a few simple APIs that
help the hardware spend
less time drawing.
Now, if you remember, overdraw
occurs when the hardware spin
cycle's drawing pixels on
the screen that don't end up
contributing to the final
image-- for example, when
the Nav Drawer slides out in
front of your current activity.
See, we still have to draw
all those original items
under the Nav Drawer,
which aren't actually
visible to the final image
and thus wasted time.
Now, the Android system
will try to reduce overdraw
as much as it can by trying to
avoid drawing any items that
are completely hidden by
another opaque surface.
Now, for example,
all those labels
underneath the Nav Drawer won't
actually waste processing time.
But sadly, this technique
doesn't extend itself
to complex custom
views where you're
overriding the on draw method.
In these cases, the
underlying system
doesn't have insight
into how you're
drawing your content, which
makes it really hard for it
to know what to avoid.
But you can help the system
get a better visibility
into this process by utilizing
the canvas.cliprect API.
This function allows you to
define the drawable boundaries
for your given view.
Only the stuff inside
the clipping rectangle
will actually be drawn.
Everything else will be ignored.
This API can be really
helpful for custom views
with lots of
overlapping components.
For example, if you've got
a set of stacked UI cards,
you can determine what
part of the current card
is hidden by the
one on top of it
and set your cliprect bounds
to ignore that area entirely.
What's nice here is that
cliprect helps save performance
on the CPU and on the GPU.
See, on the CPU side,
each one of those canvas
draw commands have a bit of
overhead associated with them
once they're actually
submitted to OpenGL ES to draw.
So any draw commands that lie
entirely outside the cliprect
won't be submitted
to the hardware
and thus won't
produce that overhead.
Now, anything that's partially
intersecting the cliprect
will still be drawn, which
is why, on the GPU side,
cliprect will help define an
exclusion rectangle that allows
the GPU at a per pixel level to
avoid coloring anything that's
actually clipped.
In addition to
cliprect, you can also
use the quickreject
API, which will
allow you to test for cliprect
intersection inside of your
on draw function.
If you've got some
part of your view
that takes up a lot
of processing time,
quickreject can help tell you
if it's outside the cliprect
and let you skip all of
that processing altogether.
And don't forget that you can
see the impact of overdraw
right on your device with the
help of the Show GPU Overdraw
tool.
This tool visualize
how much overdraw
is happening in
your app by tinting
the pixels different colors.
Lots of red is really
bad in this regard.
If you're looking to know more
about overdraw and validations
and how it affects
your performance,
make sure to check out the
rest of the Android performance
patterns resources on the web.
Oh, and don't forget to join
our Google+ community for more
great tips and tricks.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember
Perf Matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]